[موسيقى]
احب اعرف اللعبه ابي اصير الاول ابي افوز
تراجع من الجامعه رايق داخل اطقطق وادخل
العب معاك
اضافه عجبني لعبك كلمني قال تعال ادخل
مجال احتراف تعال مع التيم الشيء اللي انت
كنت العبك كضحك وناسه لا صار جديه ومنافسه
وظيفه لك
والله شوف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بس في الغالب يختار شيء مميز يعني
انا
[موسيقى]
مجال الرياضات هي نفس الالعاب لكن
المنافسه ادخل بطولات
تحديات عليها جوائز البطولات نوعين
اون لاين اون لاين تلعب وانت ببيتك
بالعاده اذا تاهلت من بطولاته اون لاين
تصير تصير فلاين اللي هي مكان محدد مثلا
سواء برا السعوديه وبالسعوديه بس يصير كل
لعيبه بمكان واحد فكثر ما قدمت وحققت
بطولات بتجيك دعوات البطولات جايه فصار
يعني الشيء اللي انت كنت العبك كضحك وناسه
لا صار جديه ومنافسه وظيفه لك
حرفيا يوميا يعني فالشهر يمكن يومين ما
العب ثلاث ايام ما العب باقي ايام كلها
العب من اربع الى من اربع وطالع حرفيا من
اربع وطالع غير الاجتماع من المدرب
غير انك تتابع يعني هذا انه
غالب يومك تلقاك على اللعبه
[موسيقى]
ولا جالس مع مدرب اللعبه
فصراحه شيء متعب اعطيك معدل ساعات لعب لعب
محترف اسبوع توقع اقل لاعب محترف
يلعب ثلاثين ساعه بالاسبوع اقل لعمتك
[موسيقى]
اي العاب كثير مو العاب مو لعبه لعبتين
تعدت مجموعه جوائزها 100 مليون ريال تقدر
تخليها مصدر دخل اساسي مئه بالمئه بس انها
تفرق على حسب اللاعب او حسب الفريق
الافريق اللي مثلا ما تقدم ما تخليها
راح تكسب طلع ملايين هو في راتب اللي هو
مصدر ثابت بس
الاعتماد الكامل على البطولات انه جوازها
كبيره اوكي مبلغ ثابت شيء مضمون لك بس لما
تلعب بطوله عليه جوائز انت تقدم الحسبه
تختلف من منظمه المنظمه على حسب المنظمه
انت او الفريق اللي انت فيه متوسطه النسب
70% للعيبه 30% منظمه يعني هذه النسبه
المتوسطه اغلب الفرق يعني تطلع مرات 35 25
بس 70% تجي للعيبه تقسمون اربعه
والله شوف
اعلى جائزتني
كامل على حسابي انا شخصيا 80 الف ريال
على طول ومن وين جاي
[موسيقى]
اذا قدرت اقدم بالمجال ابى اكمل واذا ما
قدرت ابشر برجع ادرس باي مجال انتبه في
البدايه الوضع غريب يعني مش لعب وخرابيط
وش وين المستقبل لك
بس الحين هل يكبر دعمي
[موسيقى]
في مجال انك تغش بس موجود الحكام لا
بيوقفتك لا تحاول تغشني مثلا ببجي موبايل
العبها يشيل مثلا واحد يحط اي ما ثبات ما
يتحرك ولا يسرع لاعب او او عشان يغش هذا
او شيء في برامج مركب جوالاتنا برنامج
تصور نفسك تثبت انك انت تلعب بطولات اون
لاين اللي انت ما لك ما تسمع فيها
وثاني شيء يشوف اذا في برامج تغش على
جوالك ولا لا
فنسبت انك تغش
صفر في الصفر فاصله واحد
تنتهي مسيرتي حرفيا انت مسيرتي يعني
اقل عقوبه عشر سنوات مع السلامه
[موسيقى]
لما يطلع مثلا على بطوله على بطوله صغيره
او لعب كلاسيك او يعني اشياء بسيطه او في
تيم مانجر بالتيم
يقدر يشوف اللعيبه هذه الصاعده او المواهب
يكلمهم
والله تعالى بعطيك تجربه التيم انا شايف
فيك شيء
ليه ما تجرب يمكن
تراجع راجع من الجامعه الظهر
عندي بريك ساعتين خفيف لطيف فدخلت تويتر
اشوف كوره كله يتابعون كوره وشوف واحد من
المشاهير كاتب تعال رومات ببجي موبايل
داخل تواجه من الجامعه رايق داخل اطقطق
وادخل العب مع جيم وجلد وجلد وجلد
بيجي بعد الجيم قال برسل لك اضافه عجبني
لعبك ومن بعدها قابلتها بالرياض بعد بعدها
بشهرين بعدها تقريبا بعد ما قابلتها
باسبوعين كلمني قال تعال ادخل مجال
الاحتراف تعال مع التيم جرب شو الوضع
[موسيقى]
يا عيال واحد يفلق واحد يفلك الفلانك اللي
هو اللاعب اللي يجي من ورا الخصم انا
قدامي يتيم اخلي واحد من العيال يطلع
ويكبرون لعيال كبروا لنا وقت ما نبش نخلي
واحد وراء عشان يخلينا نوصل معرق يتوقع
معروف لاي واحد يلعب بس معرق يعني واحد
حيله والله
[موسيقى]
تلقيت الرصاص ينقص دمك فلازم تهيل عشان
والله في في قاعده جماهيريه يعني
[موسيقى]
وفي ضغط جماهيري انت انت بطوله انت ودك
تنافس وتحقق البطوله لك ولجماهير
[تصفيق]
انه اذا ما ودعت يعني الله يعينك الله
يعينك
ليه ما سويتوا كذا لا سويته كذا ليه ما
طلعتوا من يمين طبعا الجمهور يشوف
الجيم كامل يعني احنا نلعب من منظورنا
منظور جميع التيمات فيجيك فاهم في انواع
جماهير طبعا في ناس يحفزون في ناس لا
والله مسوي فاهم اللي انا احسن منك ليه
تسوي كذا ولا تسوي كذا بس بالغالب التحفيز
يعني
[موسيقى]
الله يعافيك ان شاء الله اني افدتكم عاد
واستفدت مني
[موسيقى]